es gibt streit zwischen dem kanzleramt
und den bundesländern es gibt aber auch
streit zwischen den bundesländern selbst
also man ist sich bei einigen themen
wirklich überhaupt nicht einig das kann
ein fürchterlich langer tag werden heute
hier draußen pfeift ein eisiger wind
drin und in den ganzen staatskanzleien
ist das klima aber noch etwas rauer noch
kälter also da kann man froh sein dass
man draußen steht und nicht in diese
diskussion ist also nehmen wir mal das
thema schule und kita
da wird darüber diskutiert welchen teil
von schule kann man wieder aufmachen
kann die schulen überhaupt wieder öffnen
oder bleibt alles geschlossen eine
mögliche kompromisslinie aber auch die
ist noch umstritten könnte sein kita und
grundschule können geöffnet werden immer
gekoppelt an bestimmte incidents werte
aber grundsätzlich könnten die geöffnet
werden und alle jahrgangsstufen drüber
im präsenzunterricht oder eingeteilten
klassen aber eher präsenzunterricht also
homeschooling elektronisches cooling das
wäre eine kompromisslinie das ist aber
auch so gut wie alles wo sich bisher ein
kompromiss abzeichnen nach dem was wir
hören was paul hat was ich höre und alle
unsere kollegen aus der politikredaktion
hören es gibt streit um die sogenannte
korona alleine da gibt es einige
bundesländer die die machen wollen dazu
gehören sachsen wo es ohnehin schon in
der region gilt
dazu gehört thüringen und einige andere
länder die halt schwerer betroffen sind
die sind für 15 kilometer beschränkung
um den wohnort herum
wir hatten das schon einmal diskutiert
im herbst das sind so genannte umkreis
beschränkung das ist ein begriff der
kommt eigentlich aus dem führerschein
verwiesen dass man nämlich zum beispiel
bei epileptikern oder bei schweren
krankheiten
die gültigkeit des führerscheins auf
einen bestimmten radius einschränken
kann
das wäre dann quasi das würde man dann
entliehen und wurde dann in bestimmten
regionen verbieten dass man sich mehr
als 15 kilometer von seinem haus
entfernt also privat beruflich ist das
was anderes aber auch da ist momentan da
gibt es eine frage die möchte dass dazu
gehört auch dass das kanzleramt
empfangen hier gerade die ersten die
ersten minister vor also die sind alle
ein bisschen später dran nicht einmal 13
uhr hat man jetzt in behalten können
jetzt gibts die ersten vor fahrten hier
also die die krone alleine da sagen uns
jetzt leute die dann mit gehört haben es
ist nicht ganz klar ob man dann nachher
überhaupt noch direkt darüber spricht
oder ob sie jetzt schon von jetzt schon
vom vom tisch aber überraschung ist da
nicht ausgeschlossen
es gibt viele andere themen bei dem man
sich überhaupt nie
grünes und vor allem der lockdown wir
dachten ja bisher 31 januar ist in stein
gemeißelt man beschließt ihr den 31
januar die diskussion die jetzt gelaufen
ist ist kann man die lok doch eigentlich
unbegrenzt laufen lassen und sagt er
wird aufgehoben ab einer bestimmten
incidents reist unbegrenzte lockdown
wenn eine inzidenz von 50 erreicht ist
meint meine wing oder karl lauterbach
der ist die gesundheitskarte fordert ja
sogar 25
also wenn eine inzidenz wert von 50 also
50 ansteckungen 100.000 menschen
innerhalb von sieben tagen
wenn dieser wert erreicht wäre dann erst
würde der lok dann aufgehoben werden das
ist ein ganzes stück wir müssen wir
zurück gucken wann wir bei 50 waren dass
wir irgendwann im herbst das war david
darunter sind das wird ein ganzes
stückchen dauern jetzt kommen noch die
ganzen infektionszahlen von weihnachten
und von silvester drauf und da ist man
heillos zerstritten unter den
bundesländern und die bundesländer mit
dem kanzleramt wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren